i'm back hanging out with david dobrik
my next guest prides himself on solving
problems that don't exist by making
products nobody's looking for
why not it's always fun to see what he
comes up with let's get matt benedetto
in here
hey what's up man how you doing i'm
doing well how are you i am so good i
love that we've got you like two times
over this is awesome
yeah looking great okay all right so um
say hi to david dobrik as well hi matt
how are you good to see you
how are you david pretty good pretty
good all right well david actually loves
to buy random things online he just
showed me which i want both
um so we wanted him to see what you've
got so matt i understand you've been
very busy in your studio during the
pandemic right
yes this is the unnecessary studio would
you like a quick tour
yes so here we go so over here we've got
a whole slew of 3d printers so i use
these to make some of my inventions
we have the wall of unnecessary where
some of my inventions end up after i'm
done
over here we've got my little editing
and vr station i've got a whole sewing
station over here
this is a laser cutter so i can use
laser to cut like metal and all sorts of
fun stuff wow
that sounds dangerous but yes exactly
so um what have you been like you're
wearing one of your latest things right
you said i am so i this invention came
from
sort of women talking about never having
enough pocket space on their pants
so i thought instead of two pockets why
not have one giant pocket across your
butt
and so david i know you like to play
tennis so you know maybe you can have
your tennis racket there
ready to go but then you got to get some
work done you got your ipad
you've got a hairbrush to be looking
good you've got a sandwich for lunch
everything you need everything to
connect i was just gonna say i have had
the
toughest time fitting my racket into my
pockets
i just love that if you knew the size of
my ass
um a pocket on my ass well
it sort of gives whole new meaning to
junk in the trunk yeah just a lot and
more
it's just a thing that's amazing all
right well matt said david at me
um another one of his practical
inventions it is a necklace and i'm
very curious okay it's very it's a
statement everyone should have one
it reconnects in the back it's warm and
so you know when you're buying some
chicken nuggets you know you want to get
the 20 piece
but sometimes you can't eat them all so
this is called the nuggy necklace
so each container magnet magnetically
comes off
and you have a chicken nugget so you can
have it later
maybe only half of it put the other half
back snap it back in
how long has this been in here yeah i
know
i shut them like two or three weeks ago
they should be fine
thank god nuggets don't go bad for like
five years
i'm not even kidding you my kids would
love this
this is this is amazing so how is your
nugget necklace do you like it david
yeah i mean i'm i'm obsessed with it i i
would like a nuggy belt too just in case
so i
i can have more tickets across the chest
around the waist just like
40 nuggets non-stop so wait matt wait
what's the last invention you have for
us today
so the very last one so i just won the
webby for the social weird category
and it was my very first award that i
won so i thought
i want everyone to know that i won an
award
i built a harness to show off my webby
award
non-stop and i heard uh i heard that i
should be making a separate one that's
the
emmy harness because i believe we have
anything hey
i did congratulations believe it i'm
still shocked and think it might have
been an accident but it's fine
um i love it you've got a baby bjorn on
from a mama
it looks from my perspective so there we
go
so the webby harness on on the strap it
just says look at my award because i
just want everyone to know
that i know wow award-winning weirdo
oh my gosh perfectly this is a real
thing
so we're about to tape the voice and i
totally want to have that so i can put
my voice trophies
on them and just walk around blake
shelton and just be like
upwards of these things fine yes and
that's what i'm going to do on the voice
that would be amazing
would you wear that harness davin
again i already have i already have too
much too much ice conditioning
he too advise me he likes the nut nugget
all right so um so you you made an
invention that people can buy what is it
matt
so yeah so i just launched so after 180
inventions over the past uh
year and a half i launched the jigsaw
puzzle coffee table
so the top of the coffee table can't be
used until you solve the jigsaw puzzle
so it's sort of like ikea directions on
steroids
having of the coffee table together
before you can actually use this
functional coffee table okay well
nothing on ikea but i'm just telling you
the people that should make directions
to build anything in life
are whoever does the directions for
legos those people
have it going on it's so easy thank you
so much matt and david y'all check out
matt's book 101 unnecessary inventions
the new updated version will be out this
fall
[Music]
you